the Germany has unveiled the biggest
stimulus package in its history in an
effort to lift the country out of a
coronavirus induced recession the 130
billion euro plan will slash taxes hand
money to families and incentivize
businesses to keep training workers some
quarter of a million people lost their
jobs in the month of May alone bringing
the total number of unemployed here to
some three million after two days of
intense talks they emerged with 50
billion euros more than anyone expected
and a dramatic surprise aim to get
Germans reaching for their wallets v80
will be cut by 3% until the end of the
year via misunder Fazal know that the
lockdown is reaching an end we need to
make sure that everyone has the courage
to invest again and to make sure that
the consumer demand rises to four weeks
industry leaders have lobbied hard for
emergency help in the end there was a
little for everyone there will be a
great number of further measures aimed
at reviving the economy and we will
agree on a bridging program using
exiting means from middle and small
businesses among the measures families
will receive 300 euros per child the
government will help local
municipalities cover billions in tax
shortfalls there will be bonuses for
companies that keep training programmes
despite the pandemic and purchase
incentives for electric cars missing
amid the measures long hoped for
purchased premiums for cars with petrol
and diesel engines here even the mighty
auto industry could not prevail joining
us now for more is our political
correspondent Kate Brady good moins UK
Germany tends to be highly allergic when
it comes to big spending programs taking
on debt are we witnessing a general
shift and how Berlin handles the economy
we certainly are seen a shift in of
course these are unprecedented
circumstances that Germany and the rest
of the rest of the world finds itself in
right now and of course it took some 21
hours of marathon talks but in the end
we know now that the the German the
governing German parties are going to be
plowing some 130 billion euros into
rebooting the German economy and this
certainly is a shift in in the behavior
here in Germany and the days of penny
pincher rather sent pinching seem to be
over at least for now in the initial
response to the economic fallout of the
corona virus pandemic and let's not
forget that this is also on top of the
750 billion euro financial a package
that was also announced by the German
government back in the end of at the end
of March so we certainly are seeing a
shift here in Berlin and some massive
levels of spending as well what what are
some of your big takeaways from this
deal so lots of wide-ranging measures
but I think some of the most prominent
takeaways things like families they're
going to be provided with an extra 300
euros per child on top of that v80 here
in germany is temporarily going to be
cut from 19 percent to 16 percent and
we're also seeing a government supported
rebates on purchases of electric cars
and also interestingly included in this
package is some fifty billion euros then
that's a fund that set to address things
like digitalization even innovation and
also climate change within the german
economy and these are issues that
germany has really been falling behind
on in recent years so I think this
package is certainly being used to take
on some new opportunities as well
Ikeda are Germans comfortable with with
this new approach how's the deal being
received in Germany it has been received
quite well of course they in this the
circumstances that we find ourselves in
right now require a huge response like
this but of course outside of Germany
there our concerns especially among
weaker economies especially within the
European Union and also especially the
the eurozone that the sheer size of this
German splurge spending splurge could
indeed actually worsen the financial
imbalances within
the European within the European single
market and also within the eurozone so
certainly some concerns outside of
Germany but this is within the country
seem very much as the boost that the
German economy needs okay thanks so much
for that the markets looking at this
very closely today DWS financial
correspondent Chelsea Delaney joins us
now from Frankfurt for more Chelsea good
day to you
a lot of investor expectations for this
package how the markets been reacting
this morning well a lot of investor
optimism as well this this is a bit of a
good surprise for the markets we'd
already seen the dax really doing a lot
better than its then other indexes over
the past couple days it's about it's up
about 8% it's almost regained its entire
loss from the coronavirus crisis over
the past several weeks so the German
stock market certainly has been
outperforming this this package is
really the first step towards a recovery
for the German economy it's important to
note that the economy still is going to
shrink this year it's still expected to
contract about 6% even with these
stimulus measures but the German
government is is certainly laying the
groundwork for a recovery through the
rest of the year a lot of these measures
are supposed to have a pretty broad
impact things like tax cuts for the for
the broader economy and in particular
these funds that are going to help
businesses especially in hard-hit areas
like tourism and hospitality all of that
it should really help the German economy
outperform throughout the rest of the
year okay Chelsea thanks so much for
that from Frankfurt